samuelsson ist präsident der vereinigten
staaten man wird eingeschworen
wie office of president auf die united
states geht anschließend ins oval office
und aus dem nichts heraus geht auf
einmal der alarm los und man wird in
einen bunker geführt und muss dann
innerhalb kürzester zeit entscheiden wie
man auf einen massiven angriff
gegnerischer streitkräfte mit internet
continental raketen reagiert
[Musik]
ja
ernennt projekt nehmen wir personen in
virtual reality in nukleare
krisensituationen versetzen und das
bedeutet dass sie eben in sehr kurzer
zeit eine entscheidung treffen müssen
die weltweite auswirkungen haben kann
man das projekt ist der amerikanischen
nuklearstrategie nachempfunden werden
damit zwei ziele wollen einerseits
zeigen dass dieser mechanismus der
kurzen entscheidungswegen sehr
schwieriges die meisten leute kommen gar
nicht dazu eine wirklich gute
entscheidungen zu treffen man hat kaum
informationen und eben wenig zeit
trotzdem ist die strategie darauf
ausgelegt das zweite ziel ist es ein
langfristiges ziel war das eben auch
erforschen und sehen wie sich leute
entscheiden welche mechanismen in dieser
entscheidung eben eine rolle spielt
mit ihm gibt es die optionen des
nuklearen gegenschlag dass wir den usa
im moment geplant ist sind die
gegenschlags optionen gegen gegenüber
den feinden attackiert diskontiert
genesis option wann ich habe mich jetzt
in diesem fall für die kleinste lösung
entschieden aber es ist ja wirklich
schon es ist ganz komisch also man muss
dann auch noch eine bestätigung geben
für einen code und auf einmal läuft die
zeit runter und man hat wirklich einen
atomaren gegenschlag befohlen das ist
schon ja wie gesagt man kriegt ja schon
gänsehaut wenn man so was macht charlie
solo
wir würden natürlich auch gerne dem
amerikanischen präsidenten zeigen wenn
er interesse daran hat nach allem was
wir wissen dass informationen zu sagen
eingeholt wie das stattfinden würde und
die meisten amerikanischen präsidenten
so was noch nie durchgespielt ordnung
abonnenten
[Musik]